is absolutely right that this is about
enabling the government to properly help
the most genuine and vulnerable Asylum
Seekers and refugees who come to this
country and currently because of the
influx of illegal migrants because our
modern slavery and Asylum system has
been overwhelmed thanks to the efforts
of the people smuggling and we are
unable to help those genuine victims for
whom we owe a clear Duty Shadow Minister
Stephen Kennett Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
the government's new Asylum legislation
is a sham which is set to worsen the
backlog because they don't have the
facilities to detain tens of thousands
of Asylum Seekers and because they don't
have a returns agreement in place with
the EU to send those deemed inadmissible
back and for all her taxpayer-funded
photo ops this weekend the Home
Secretary has seemingly failed to bung
the Rwandan government enough money for
them to increase the number of Asylum
Seekers they're ready to take this year
Mr Speaker for a deterrent to be
effective it has to be credible yet
these plans just empty threats so can
she tell us where she expects to detain
the tens of thousands of Asylum Seekers
forecast to arrive this year where she
expects to remove them too when Rwanda
clearly has no intention of taking more
than a very small proportion of those
who she expects to arrive this year and
when will this government get out of the
way so that labor can deliver its
five-point plan to stop the boat
Crossing
Mr Speaker I Thank The Honorable done
for his entertaining uh as a approach to
entertaining the house today but let's
just compare what the labor party has
done over the last 10 days and what the
government has done in the last 10 days
the prime minister
the in the last 10 days the Prime
Minister and I have secured a big deal
with the French to increase
cross-channel cooperation I've presented
and we've voted on measures to detain
and swiftly remove illegal migrants and
this weekend I met with refugees who
have successfully been resettled in
Rwanda and seen the accommodation that
people will be using what's what's
he's been on Twitter
she tweeted in the last 10 days Labor's
poetry excuse for a plan half of it
stuff we're already doing the other half
is their plan for open borders and
unlimited migration what I suggest they
do is get off Twitter get to Rwanda and
I'll show them how to stop the boats SMP
spokesperson Alison thulas thank you Mr
Speaker freedom from torture have talked
about the impact and torture survivors
of the anti-asylum bill calling it a
betrayal of the commitments following
the short review seven babies born to
mothers and home of home office
accommodation since 2020 have died so
it's no surprise that women for Refugee
women and the RCM have opposed the home
office's plans and the Scotland's
children's commissioner has warned that
the plans to detain and remove children
breach this government's obligations
under the UN convention and the rights
of the child there is nothing about
protecting Asylum Seekers welfare that
this bill will fix so will she accept
the harm that she's causing yeah
trip well we take very seriously our
duties to everybody who is within our
care and our measures will always of
course ensure that the proper well-being
and Welfare provision is available to
those who are vulnerable but let me just
say this she The Honorable lady has
absolutely no right to lecture this
government on how to support Asylum
Seekers when her own Nation royally
fails to take any or sufficient numbers
into the Scotland
that is simply Mr Speaker not connect
this isn't this bill is not about and
about helping Asylum Seekers this is
about banning Asylum Seekers so what
does it say about the home secretaries
models that she believes Rwanda would be
a blessing for Asylum Seekers but when
they come here she calls them a swarm
and an invasion
the problem that The Honorable lady is
laboring under is that she is in her
opposition to our plans she is siding
with the people smuggling gangs she is
effectively
full practice of exploitation of
vulnerable people coming into this
country vote for our measures stop the
people smuggling gangs and stop the
boats
how about help
question number two Please Mr Speaker
Minister Mr Speaker with your permission
I'd like to group this question with
question 14. the Prime Minister made a
commitment on the 30th of December to
clear the Legacy backlog of Asylum
applications over the course of the year
and I'm pleased to report that we are on
track to deliver this we've already
doubled the number of caseworkers that
are on course to double the number again
we're streamlining processes to reduce
unnecessary paperwork whilst maintaining
robust standards the productivity of
caseworkers has more than doubled since
the start of the Year hello bardel thank
you very much Mr Speaker my constituents
Mr and Mrs Leeson have UK residency but
are American citizens they live in my
Livingston constituency but they and
they are highly skilled but they've had
huge issues getting their niece Carissa
who they have guardianship over for a
visa to come to Scotland now a U.S court
has ruled that they are her guardians
but they are being told they're gonna
have to wait six months for an
administrative review would he meet with
me to discuss this case because my
constituent and her niece are currently
stuck in the US and this family are
being separated
well I'd be happy to look into the case
that The Honorable lady raises I would
just say that with respect to visas the
UK Visa service is now meeting or
exceeding every one of its service
standards and so the government is
providing a good service generally but
I'd be happy to look into that
particular case
Mr Speaker the minister says that the
government is providing a good service
that's not the experience that I've seen
not just with Asylum cases but across
the piece with so many cases of work
visas visitor visas and so on delayed
longer than I've seen in the 18 years
that I've served as an MP including in
the role that he so when will he get a
grip it's all very well same dealing
with
dealing with this one area another area
goes badly wrong when's he going to get
a grip
well I prefer to trade in facts uh the
facts are that in every single one of
the Visa categories the UK Visa service
is at or exceeding the service standard
it is it is it is correct that we moved
a number of individuals off work and
visit visas to ensure that we met the
homes for Ukraine schemes demand last
year but those people are now back on
the job and the service is performing
well if the right honorable lady has
specific examples I'd be happy to look
into them
Joe Mayu speak of the the backlog of
Asylum uh Seekers is increasing the need
for accommodation now we've just heard
the outrage of the spokesman for the SMP
so can my right honorable friend update
the house and the progress the Scottish
government is making in housing similar
numbers of Asylum Seekers to the rest of
the United Kingdom
so today's the latest there from The
Commons where the Home Secretary swella
bravaman was answering questions put to
her by MPS following her trip to Rwanda
some heated moments there um an
opposition MP put to her that this bill
imprisons innocent children and pushes
victims of traffickers to predators and
also accused her of blaming destitute
people to mask her own failures some
stinging words coming in from swella
Brotherman who said that in last 10 days
the Prime Minister has secured a deal
with France also said interestingly that
she met refugees who successfully have
been settled in Rwanda and she accused
labor of wanting open Borders or strick
he is an MP of siding with the people
smuggling gang
let's bring you some other breaking news
now Boris Johnson has now submitted
evidence to the Privileges committee as
part of his claim that he did not
mislead MP parliaments about what he
knew about lockdown parties in Downing
streets let's just bring in our
John Craig there our Deputy political
our chief political correspondent give
you a right title there John um just
just brings up to date with what's in
the the details that you've seen
well we haven't seen the Boris Johnson's
evidence yet although we will later
today we believe unless the committee uh
decides to spend several hours